[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai un contrat son journal pour livrer
l'hôtel
j'espère qu'elles seront sociaux tels
voyages remporté à aubenas et bâle
zimbawe son côté des petits commérages
[Musique]
le petit écho de la forêt
c'est très serré où il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyant quelles sont les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui au en haut il coûtait cher
téléphone
la vie est belle eau c'est pourtant vrai
on a trop souvent tendance à l'oublier
alors qu'à la vie est belle
oh non conan o non tu ne trouves pas que
la vie est belle non et pourquoi non
parce que tu as tort que tu dis je ris
de donner un truc pour voir la vie belle
île trucs et b à chaque fois quand il a
un pépin depuis tant qu'on a la santé
qui rythme la vie réelle zip cadeau si
tu qu'on me trouve plus de carottes
bof ça tu es galapagos à la santé tu
vois ta marge mon truc
vous avez dit aux spurs décide
d'expérimenter le truc 2e guillaume oui
tosca sais tu ce qui t'arrive non coire
edwards ne veux plus te parler bon tant
qu'on a la santé et droit oui tosca sais
tu ce qui t'arrive ne cois dijon ne veut
plus travailler avec toi bord d'un canal
à sainté et canon le 2é pas l'air de
marcher et tout ce qu'un poursuivi son
expérimentation au max je suis bien
contente de te voir ici max une nouvelle
et rentable annoncé qu'elle ol
tu avais bien cacher tes from à hama et
bien louis le renard tu les a tous vos
lits basse tu apprendras à saintes est
incroyable le tout deux ils continuent
de marcher tous cas ne renoncera pas à
son enquête ne connaissait pas la
nouvelle isadore non je ne la connais
pas
il paraît qu'on va fermer l'opéra deux
boss boss tant qu'on a la santé que
c'est irritant
syfy je suis bien contente de te
rencontrer hu a aussi tout ce que tu ne
connais pas la nouvelle tu ne sais pas
ce qui t'arrive nous eh bien tu ne
pourras plus jamais faire de ménage un
drone à la santé que cela menace qui
juste mot bory's passait par la borie
santos que tout va bien pour toi
non moi est le plus lourdement tenu
alors tout va mal pas toi pouf cancun à
la fin tu trop c'est trop le truc de
zips marche pour tout le monde souffre
pour moi je vais en faire une maladie en
effet tosca en tomba malade ont dû
appeler le grand docteur hippocrate quoi
et quoi et laiteries malades
didier ait mal à la tête
mal à l'estomac mal aux reins qu elle
percée dans ses bras et ce n'est pas
tout et pour montrer mon intestin trop
longue
quant au x 100 x il quitte ou froid faim
à part ça eh bien je crois qu'elle ne va
pas bien de tous
elle est très malade
bof
tant qu'on a la santé et oui le truc
deux hypermarchés aussi sur notre brave
tosca elle fut guérie sur le champ cher
téléphone
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous dire tant
qu'on a la santé
rendez vous pour une prochaine édition
du petit écho de la santé qu'est ce que
je raconte dans la forêt
docteur
[Musique]